tenga una sonrisa que por casi tres años
fue difícil de observar menguan su hija
mayor del fundador de la empresa huawei
alcanzó un acuerdo con la justicia
estadounidense de enjuiciamiento
diferido que le otorgó la libertad las
aguas men exhortó estoy sin volver el
acuerdo para aplazar el enjuiciamiento
de la señora me permitió al fiscal
general retirar la autorización para
proceder a la extradición
si la señora mena ahora puede viajar
libremente sin condiciones
y durante los últimos tres años mi vida
ha cambiado completamente fue un momento
perturbador para mí como madre esposa y
ejecutiva de una empresa
en la comunidad
fue aprendida por las autoridades
canadienses en diciembre de 2018 bajo el
argumento de eeuu de que incurrió en
delitos financieros una situación que
elevó las ya complicadas relaciones
entre washington y beijing
es bastante obvio para cualquier persona
justa e imparcial que la acción reciente
en contra de una empresa en particular y
un individuo chino no es un acto
judicial sino un movimiento político
deliberado para derribarlos él está allá
tras el acuerdo canadá recibió la buena
nueva de que sus dos ciudadanos
detenidos bajo cargos de espionaje
fueron liberados
hace dos minutos el avión que transporta
a maikel corbin y maikel spaceball
abandonó el espacio aéreo chino y se
dirigen a casa
no obstante tal como lo dio a conocer un
informe del centro de seguridad
cibernética de lituania recientemente la
confiabilidad de los equipos de origen
chino sigue siendo cuestionada